It really depends who you are and sort
of what you've done.
I think a lot of people,
um,
what did they say?
A perfection is the enemy of the good or
something like that.
I think a lot of people will put the
stuff off because they want to do the
right thing.
And I think logically the way to
approach your own personal,
uh,
situation in terms of the environment is
to take some time to a carbon
calculator,
figuring out where you have the most
impact,
focus on those things first,
et cetera.
I think the,
the challenge with that is that people
may put that off and put that off
because it's a big thing.
They just want to do it right and they
want to be sure.
So I,
I try to counsel people just,
just get started,
pick something.
It doesn't really matter what,
pick something that matters to you and
that just feels right and just start and
I think that gets you on the path.
And then,
you know,
if you want to be more strategic,
great,
by all means get up,
get on one of those carbon calculators,
figure out where you can have your
impact and sort of do that.
So,
um,
I think that's,
I've met,
that's a big one.
I think in terms of general concepts,
there's a very,
very simple one,
just small is sexy and it just apply.
It applies to,
I say in Jasper applies to everything.
Like we just,
we have this perception that we need a
lot of things or,
or,
or volume or what have you in order to
be happy and we've just don't.
So whether it's architecture,
you know that the houses have gone from
some close to a thousand square feet and
like 50 years ago to close to two and a
half,
literally two and a half times as big
while the fat average family size has
shrunk.
Oh,
it's not like we are a lot happier now
than we were in the 50s.
So you can live a great life and,
and um,
in a,
in a much smaller home.
And,
and by doing that,
because the space is much smaller,
you save on heating,
you save on cooling,
you see save on lighting,
you save on furnishing.
And it just makes for an overall simpler
life.
So I think focused on small smells
great.
And that can be cars,
that can be architecture,
that can be the size of your wardrobe,
that can be the,
your number of,
uh,
we can John's via plane.
But I think just,
just focus on that.
I think if we were,
if we were very vocal with both our
dollars
in terms of what,
what products and services we're willing
to support and what not,
um,
and in terms of the political process,
I think that that in itself can have a
tremendous impact because it also
impacts the people around you.
So it sort of covers the consumer and
the personal aspect it sends a message
to and sends a message to,
uh,
to,
to government.
So I think if we were a lot more vocal
and a lot less concerned about what
other people
thought,
I think that.